got new toys oh man I'm so excited I
almost dropped this camera we're gearing
up for the holidays and we're doing some
massive cooking videos because you know
why not like Justine what's your channel
about I don't know is it cooking I don't
know is it tech probably is it vlogs I'm
not sure you guys your guess is as good
as mine
but we've got so much stuff over here
all prepped for cooking but something
has finally arrived I've been waiting
months for this this is a new light this
is Nick hi hey oh gosh oh gosh oh boy
this thing is so incredible yes I'm
ready my godson that is an LED panel my
Wow look at this it's beautiful it's
actually beautiful look at that mounting
plate built-in it's like a flat-screen
TV
whoa I know I'm good and surprisingly
light too like if there's not much to it
like it but it's not light no it's like
oh oh gosh puns they're not really yeah
for the view do you know how to set it
up I'm I can figure it out but I look at
inventory list and it also comes with
peace even this light stand is awesome
like this is so nice I'm excited kitchen
game going strong so soon
[Music]
that's the coolest lightweight design
I've ever seen a spider in the bag and
I'm not a fan of bugs and you're really
not a fan of spiders
no not not a big spider guy yeah you
definitely can this is a much more
industrial light than I'm used to cuz
where do you in this light is too good
for me well if you need to use it at any
point remember that this was just
supposed to be like a super chill easy
blog so you could dim it and it has
tungsten and daylight's you can
basically set it how bright you want it
and what temperature you want oh look at
that
this is incredible hey let me just tell
you what you don't need when you're
first starting out making YouTube videos
I mean this is honestly this is a dream
come true
not one this is down the rabbit hole
Anton power batteries are those big
batteries that you see at the end of
like film cameras when you watch behind
the scenes oh yeah it doesn't have one
it's got two oh you can hook two
batteries onto that and you'd probably
never have to recharge them for the
whole this is awesome three completely
different types of diffe you
and you can stack yeah I guess they will
melt that and I'll work on this over
here so the mounting is about to happen
there we go
so where do you think we'll need it we
want to go up and point down to prove
capper looks great
velcro everywhere
all right let's try this thing out let's
plug it in I'm excited this is Wow
shooting Christmas videos christmas came
early for mommy
this is the best unintentional unboxing
video that i've ever done
all right we're missing uh that's what
we need okay
videos are gonna look live okay plug
this one in are you controlling from
this one here's our controls blown off
we've got power we've got power put it
up to the max are you are you ready
because I'm freaking a help you're like
doc right on and back to the future is
so bright oh wow this is nuts
oh yeah we have to worry about that
reflection off this stupid it up
refrigerator I got you
raise it up yeah me and look at this we
can all watch stop it yes wait go back
again oh this is
I'm gonna need Sun Tan Lotion me too oh
my gosh yeah we're definitely gonna need
the diffusion like no I like it to be
really bright I can't like it's hurting
my eyes
[Music]
Wow wait
[Applause]
[Music]